The faster you move the slower time goes,
but… how slow?
And how fast?
What does it all mean!?!
Howdy nerds and friends, thanks for checking
out DNews today, I'm Trace.
There are things about theoretical and mathematically-proven
physics that are difficult to see in practice,
but of those things… there is one that is
no longer simply theoretical, we can actually
DO it.
Einstein's Theory of Special Relativity states
that the faster something travels, the slower
time appears to move relative to a stationary
observer.
To test the time dilation part of the TSR
massive experiments had to be conducted.
In 1971, the Hafele (ha-fi-la) and Keating
Experiment flew four atomic clocks on airplanes
going around the world and compared the time-shift
from those clocks to the atomic clock at the
National Observatory in Washington, D.C.,
and JUST like Einstein predicted the airborne
clocks were going SLOWER.
Think about it.
When you're on an airplane, you're aging slower
than your Mom.
Unless of course, she's on the airplane too….
as long as we're thinking about it, time dilation
theory says airline pilots might be aging
slower than their ground crews… think about
it.
Not a lot slower, mind you, but slower.
Once we started going to space, time dilation
became a thing we actually had to deal with.
GPS satellites, for example, are 20,000 km
up going 14,000 km/hour.
So, relative to an observer on the ground,
the GPS satellites are going to lose about
7 microseconds per day!
It doesn't seem like a lot, but knowing PRECISELY
what time it is, is extremely important for
measuring your exact location on the planet.
If they let this go unchecked GPS would fail,
so they have to correct for Special Relativity,
just so I can find the nearest Shake Shack.
Usually, before now, scientists used mathematics
or space travel to test these out-there theories.
Special relativity says, the faster you go,
the slower time goes.
If you travelled a year at 95% the speed of
light; you'd age one year, and people on Earth
would age 3.2 years!
But if you were going 50% the speed of light
it would only be 1.15 years.
The effect get's stronger as you go faster.
A German study published this week has shown
you can create the time dilation effect IN
THE LAB!
Which is HUGE news for physics.
The experiment, published in Physical Review
Letters, explains how these German scientists
used a heavy ion storage ring to accelerate
charged lithium particles to almost 40 percent
the speed of light.
A storage ring is sort of like the ghost containment
box in Ghostbusters, but for charged particles.
Once the ions were travelling at top speed,
the scientists shot two laser lights at them,
one in front and one behind, and then measured
the light absorption rate.
Think of it like sonar or radar, they're measuring
the amount of energy that comes back…
Because they had two lasers and the speed
of light is constant -- they could use the
Doppler[a] effect // rrreeeerrrrr // to figure
out the time dilation those ions were experiencing.
DAMN that's complicated.
If you want to read a full explainer, check
out Ars Technica.
The reason this is so huge, is because we
don't have to measure the changes on spacecraft,
or use assumptions related to the movement
of planets or astronomical bodies.
On top of that, it verifies, yet again, that
Einstein was a badass, and the Standard Model
of Physics is accurate.
What do you think of news like this?
Interested?
Excited?
Anything else you want to know about speed
and time dilation?
Speaking of speed, thanks once again to Subaru
for making this episode possible.
Especially the all-new 2015 Subaru Legacy.
Every sedan has its benefits, but only one
combines them all.
It’s not just a sedan.
It’s a Subaru.
But, back to time dilation, it seems like
we just started DNews and we're almost to
1 million subs!
If you're watching this, and you haven't yet
subscribed, please take a sec and hit that
sub button, and share this with your friends.
Even if you don't, we still love you.
And thank you SO much for watching.